you're crafty dude on [ __ ] mate man
would you sit she has to check me I
heard dude yeah a couple of things you
did already okay dude
so this is what I'm saying dude I just
wash my hair today I know you look great
what I was saying though is is that you
accused me of making tunnels mm-hmm you
I didn't say that messaging mightier
checkmate I would never do clever pun
very clever on your podcast we talked
about how you can't tell us a different
tell us apart
Asians that's not true I know he's from
layoffs I know but if you saw him in the
states there was other five other Laos
guys would you go that's that dude from
tiger belly oh you'd be like no that's
five Laos guys I'm like that's the guy
from the cruise first of all if you had
a tag names I just said Rico on it you
get [ __ ] all but so and look man I'm
trying to work with you guys you know
[Music]
with the JK guys I know dude yeah a lot
of them are Vietnamese a lot of them are
from Mexico
there's not one there's two Mexicans
there seconds yeah who knows what there
is I don't see colors bro and I'll see
color people damn [ __ ] mate again yeah
you know what I'm saying
are there any racial slurs pawn I would
never say I wouldn't say no you would
never say that bad now that somebody's
are there already slurs that why people
get offended by oh dude I'll tell you
what offends me if somebody says redneck
that offends me oh why because I'm not a
redneck and people say it a lot of times
it makes me mad you know but they
probably say it to you in a joking
matter right I mean I don't know you're
pretty sophisticated for a redneck but
if you say something to somebody you
know in a defense it just I guess it
matters how they take it so something if
somebody does say it and I'll be like
you know I don't like I don't like being
called that you know right but rednecks
it can't be as bad as the n-word or
[ __ ] oh I'm not saying it's could I
say that she'll be you know I'm not
calling you a [ __ ] yeah so no I mean I
I don't know man
I think for different you know here's
the thing different people affecting
people differently I mean here's another
thing like I mean people like that were
slaves you know or that were those
people are all gone now
you know those people aren't with us
anymore so the effect that a word is
gonna have it's not gonna be the same on
somebody today as it is gonna be have
been on some that story's very true
that's true you know there's no way it
can be yeah you know but yeah I don't
know what it's like to be called certain
things certain things don't affect me
you know I'm saying you call me crippled
you know I'm saying like you're not
crippled though I'm not crippled so I
wouldn't that wouldn't if I wouldn't
hurt my feelings very much you know you
call me you know
pervo or something or you know yeah you
know you do have a pervy vibe about you
yeah do you really do I think you do I
think it's kind of cute but yeah yeah
but I'm also privy
you think your provider is cute I think
some of it is they don't think is it
when I get real tired I can barely see I
can barely up miles and it kind of skis
[Music]